bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo une grosse vidéo
aujourd'hui je vais pas vous cacher tout
simplement parce que j'ai envie de vous
faire part de mes réflexions de mes
trouvailles concernant l'avenir du mc eu
et de ce qui va lier le tout car le mc
hué clairement relancé notamment grâce à
la fin de l'eau qui on sort clairement
de l'arc de l'infini pour rentrer dans
celui du multivers du cosmic des
réalités il y a clairement plein de
choses intéressantes à dire et à
théoriser
nous avons déjà émis beaucoup de
mystères via l'eau qui d'ailleurs je
vous invite à voir les deux précédentes
vidéos car ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
c'est un petit peu la suite entre
guillemets il est temps on va dire de
rentrer dans du concret du poste l'eau
qui comme je vous avais promis avec
spider man 3 docteur strange de etc etc
et bien évidemment n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à la chaîne vous êtes déjà 80
2000 un très grand merci à vous un
sincèrement il a clairement plein de
vidéos à faire d'autres sujets a
théorisé etc et j'ai clairement envie de
partager ça avec pour commencer la
réflexion je ne pouvais pas avoir
meilleure introduction pour la vidéo
c'est la fameuse théorie reliant oujda
vision et loki vous avez été nombreux
mais vraiment nombreux amants parlé et
je vais vous dire clairement ce que j'en
pense et
et on va voir que ça peut découler sur
de belles choses
tiens d'ailleurs je préfère le préciser
comme ça dès maintenant le temps que je
m'en rappelle mais évidemment tout ce
que je vous dis et c'est assez
personnelle c'est ma vision des choses
se sont simplement mes idées mes
réflexions et il est possible que rien
ne soit vrai je me bats simplement sur
les comics et les dernières informations
que nous avons sur le mc comme des
déclarations et c'est donc la théorie
wendat vision liée à l'eau qui pour ceux
qui ne la connaîtraient pas c'est que si
l'on superpose les deux derniers
épisodes des séries respectives avec le
même timer et bien la réaction de celui
qui demeure le moment où ils semblent
surpris car nous venons de dépasser le
point ultime de la fin des temps colle
parfaitement avec le moment où wendat
devient la véritable scarlet witch
je ne vais pas vous mentir pour moi
c'est une coïncidence 1 ça fait même
presque un petit peu théorie du complot
d'ailleurs pour la directrice de l'ot
qui kate et ron c'est également une
coïncidence mais bon après c'est kevin
fait guy le boss donc tout est possible
néanmoins si vous voulez une belle
théorie une belle symbolique autour de
cette liaison
j'en ai une que j'ai imaginé car
évidemment dans le mc eu tout est
connecté donc wendat lots qui ont
forcément un lien tout d'abord il faut
vous remémorer quelque chose que je vous
avais expliqué dans la vidéo précédente
c'est la thématique de la boucle ce qui
est bien avec le mc us et que s'est
calqué sur notre monde
même si c'est de la science fiction avec
des super pouvoirs et cetera eh bien il
ya toujours une base scientifique et une
certaine logique
comme pour le voyage dans le temps d'un
game par exemple du coup concernant
cette thématique de la boucle il faut se
pencher sur une des grandes théories de
notre univers
une théorie qui tente d'expliquer
l'origine de l'univers
car en gros l'univers est en constante
expansion il s'agrandit de jour en jour
pour simplifier la chose mais à
l'origine
cela veut dire qu'il était beaucoup plus
petit il y a eu un point de départ
quelque chose d'infiniment petit qui
devient infiniment grand nous
connaissons tous la théorie comme quoi
il ya eu un instant 0 entre guillemets
le néant puis le big bang est arrivé et
l'univers s'est formé en gros mais ce
qui va nous intéresser
c'est la théorie de la boucle celle qui
correspond parfaitement à l'univers de
marvel et qui est établi dans les comics
c'est celle théorisant que l'univers se
forme à partir d'un précédent pour être
plus clair à la fin des temps l'univers
s'effondre et son effondrement provoque
un big bang qui va tout relancer
peut-être que les plus malins d'entre
vous ont déjà compris où je voulais en
venir l'eau qui nous a instauré le
concept de multivers à la fin des temps
tout se relancent la ligne sacré du flux
temporel se déforme plusieurs branches
naissent c'est le renouveau du multivers
sauf qu'il est où le big bang et bien le
big bang se passe au même moment c'est
wazza le big bang
bon évidemment c'est plus une symbolique
qu'autre chose ne me faites pas dire ce
que je n'ai pas dit la scène de celui
qui demeure et de warda vision ne se
passe pas au même moment
surtout que nous sommes dans la
citadelle de la fin des temps donc bien
loin de l'époque de huanta et il n'y a
pas de raison que celui qui demeure
réagissent à wendat devenue la scarlet
witch précisément mais plutôt aux flux
temporel qui se détachent en revanche la
thématique et la symbolique sont là
rwanda est la scarlet witch et la
scarlet witch est la sorcière ultime
avec un pouvoir démesuré tellement
démesuré qu'aucun sorciers ne pensait
qu'il existait vraiment un pouvoir qui
provient de la création de l'univers qui
est lié au big bang et qui est capable
de tordre l'espace déformer la réalité
et même anéantir le cosmos c'est la
magie du chaos
donc oui wendat symbolise le big bang
elle est capable de créer lié modifier
les réalités et voyager entre mais elle
ne le sait pas encore et c'est là toute
la finalité de one la vision rwanda a le
pouvoir mais n'a pas le savoir
savoir qu'elle va acquérir dans le dark
old le livre ultime des sorciers et
sorcières retraçant tout le savoir
magique depuis l'aube des temps
du coup après luanda vision après être
devenue la scarlet witch et avoir acquis
le savoir dont elle avait besoin rwanda
est capable de dinguerie si elle le
souhaitait elle pourrait faire
réapparaître vision et ses enfants sans
avoir besoin du sexe mais ce n'est pas
ce qui l'intéresse
elle a compris la leçon avec ses erreurs
dont wang la vision
néanmoins la fin de luanda vision où
elle est capable d'entendre ses enfants
au loin pourrait être expliquée grâce à
l'eau qui est du coup au futur de la
saga
rappelez vous de la pub de l'épisode 7
de luanda vision cette dernière parle
d'un médicament antidépresseur appelé
nexus
en gros vous êtes déprimé et bien prenez
nexus créer un nexus rien que pour vous
où vous serez le centre d'attention et
où vous serez heureux et nous savons
maintenant grâce à l'eau qui est bien ce
qu'est un nexus le sexe était clairement
un ex us en quelque sorte une mini
réalité alternative dans une réalité
déjà existantes où tout était modifiée
sauf que wendat comme je vous le disais
ah le pouvoir mais pas le savoir elle ne
sait pas ce qu'elle causait réellement
dans one la vision donc là avec
l'explosion du multivers la fameuse
thématique du big bang
les réalités alternatives qui ne sont
plus stopper à cause du tva et bien les
enfants du rwanda existerait toujours
dans possiblement une branche
alternative ou autres parts dans tous
les cas ce serait bizarre d'apporter de
nouveaux personnages qui ont été
développés
et qui sont censés être important dans
l'avenir du mc sûrs comme les enfants du
rwanda précisément si c'est pour
justement les annuler à la fin de la
série de mandats vision mais surtout là
où tout ça c'est encore plus intéressant
c'est que la scène post générique de one
la vision a été modifié alors ce sont
des différences mineures 1 qui concerne
avant tout le décor comme des rajouts
d'arbres des couleurs qui ont été
rajoutés etc
mais cela a une importance capitale car
pourquoi modifier une scène
post-générique que tout le monde a déjà
vu plusieurs mois après et bien car le
lieu sera réutilisé à l'avenir forcément
nous reverrons la cabane de rwanda dans
doctor strange 2 le prochain long
métrage où elle est censée apparaître
mais cela sous-entend une autre
explication à ce sujet c'est que si ce
lieu est réutilisé à l'avenir c'est que
quelqu'un va venir chercher au rwanda
dans sa cabane son mode actuelle est
clairement de s'isoler expérimenter ses
nouveaux pouvoirs à prendre du dark auld
elle n'a plus d'attachés plus de vision
plus d'enfants elle n'a aucune raison de
se tourner vers quelqu'un elle se suffit
à elle-même et cela explique son
dédoublement également une luanda
gardienne de la maison qui joue la jeune
femme qui fait sa petite vie à la
campagne pendant que derrière elle
expérimente des choses qu'elle n'est pas
censée faire du tout et pour continuer
j'aimerais que nous parlions de la magie
du chaos par rapport à dr strange de
lots qui si il devait exister pour moi
un lien réunissant à la fois what if dr
strange de lock in one la vision est
donc tout ce qui symbolise le multivers
du coup et bien c'est chaud magot ratoma
gorath fait partie de ce qu'on appelle
les grands anciens des sortes de dieux
démons on va dire ils sont présents
depuis l'aube des temps capable de
voyager entre les réalités et ont même
régné sur la terre il y à des millions
mais c'est pas ça plus intéressant ça
c'était le contexte le plus intéressant
est que déjà et bien shuma gorath fait
partie des leaders un des grands anciens
donc gg la nuit mais surtout les grands
anciens sont à l'origine de la magie du
chaos
et là le lien avec wendat est parfait
puisque nous n'avons pas d'explications
précises sur pourquoi au rwanda et la
scarlet witch scarlet witch qui ne naît
pas scarlet witch mais qui le devient
qui ai forgé pour la de venir et cela
rejoint une explication que je vous
avais donné à l'époque de wayne la
vision c'est que pour moi ou honda dans
la scène post générique s'est logée dans
one d'abord le mont louis wind à gore
est une montagne située dans l'europe de
l'est et c'est un lieu très important
dans l'histoire du rwanda
carwin dagor est le lieu où est enfermé
tonnes un autre grand ancien encore plus
grand que chaumât gorath et qui est à
l'origine du pouvoir du chaos et qui a
transmis justement ce fameux pouvoir à
rwanda à sa naissance dans le but qu'à
l'avenir ils puissent revenir grâce à
elle et comme je vous disais le cadre
est trop parfait et trop précis pour que
ce ne soit pas une référence à ça le
truc c'est qu'étant donné que nous
sommes dans le mc eu tout est réécrit
remaniée revu pour être adapté à l'écran
l'exemple récent le plus parlant est
celui qui demeure qui est une fusion dît
morte us invariants de nathaniel
richard's et de celui qui demeure
justement le directeur du tva eh bien
l'époque je vous parlais de la possible
apparition de tonnes en tant que
prochain vilain 2
doctor strange de un vilain qui aurait
pu lier à la fois où honda et strange
pour ce fameux film
et bien si justement l'histoire dr
fusionner avec shuma gorath pour
proposer quelque chose d'inédit
l'occasion est trop parfaite pourquoi
car shuma gorath est entre guillemets
confirmé pour être le prochain vilain de
doctor strange 2 et shuma gorath est un
très grand méchant des histoires de
doctor strange au même titre que
dormammu ce dernier permet de tout lier
ensemble puisque déjà par rapport à
luanda il y a moyen de proposer un
background pour la magie du chaos avec
la réécriture d'octobre en chaume agora
tu avec également au wynn d'accord
pourquoi le lieu a été refait et
pourquoi il est si symbolique et c'est
par rapport au big bang également
puisque chaume agora tu es né à l'aube
des temps donc dans la thématique de la
boucle avec l'univers qui se relance
avec un nouveau big bang et c'est un
nouveau multivers cela donne naissance à
shuma gorath en gros donc son arrivée en
quelque sorte le multivers lui ouvre les
portes pour interagir avec rwanda et se
servir d'elle donc comme une naissance
du vilain en quelque sorte
donc le fameux lien avec l'eau qui du
coup puisque relié au multivers par
rapport à strange comme je vous disais
c'est l'un de ses plus grands ennemis
mais là où les étoiles sa ligne encore
plus c'est que doctor strange et spider
man ont combattu chaumât gorath ensemble
dans les comics spider et strange sont
de véritables alliés là bas et
concernant what if
cela pourrait être l'introduction du
vilain en lui-même pour doctor strange 2
puisque le trailer de la série nous
montre captain carter en train de
combattre une entité verte avec des
tentacules et justement nous savons que
shuma gorath sera dans dr strange d'eux
et qu'ils voyagent à travers les
réalités mais aussi il y à de grosses
rumeurs voire des déclarations qui
affirme que captain carter serait adapté
en live action pour apparaître aussi
dans doctor strange 2 sachant que what
if explorerait de multiples
qualités naissantes à cause de
l'apparition du multivers donc des
histoires canonique pour l'univers du
mca et bien tout serait lié d'ailleurs
shuma gorath correspond parfaitement à
un monstre de l'horreur et nous savons
que c'est la thématique du film un film
horrifique
bref d'ailleurs je le précise quand même
au cas où mais ce n'est peut-être et
même sûrement pas shuma gorath que
carter affronte dans le trailer de what
if
sans oublier évidemment aussi notre
fameux gang gang le conquérant l'ennemi
ultime de la phase d'ailleurs j'ai un
petit peu omis d'en parler mais dans les
comics immo russes tentent d'empêcher au
rwanda d'avoir des enfants car pour lui
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait tout
chambouler un et anéantir le cosmos se
créent le chaos quoi un parallèle que
l'on retrouverait presque dans le mca
avec rwanda qui créent des illusions de
ses enfants mais qui au final avec le
multivers pourrait bien devenir vrai
nous allons conclure sur spider man dont
nous avons peu traitée pour le moment
évidemment spider man et strange ont un
véritable lien dans les comics ils ont
combattu plusieurs fois ensemble ils se
sont entraidés et sont presque devenus
des amis du moins un profond respect
existe entre les deux personnages donc
le fit est attendue néanmoins je vous
avoue avoir un petit problème concernant
spider man no way comme on sait un petit
problème mineur ils seront expliquées
puisque effectivement il était attendu
que tobey maguire et andrew garfield
fassent leur retour docteur octopus a
été confirmée également il vient de la
première trilogie de spider man c'est le
même acteur le même personnage bref et
venom 2 devrait d'ailleurs aussi apporté
une petite explication sur pourquoi il
n'y a pas de spider man dans son univers
donc comprend à moitié que ce serait
possiblement tom
endin le spider man que l'on connaît bon
bref quoi c'est vraiment un beau bazar
est justement le problème que j'ai par
rapport à ça c'est que cette manoeuvre
entre deux studios
eh bien cela ne concerne plus le
multivers mais l'homme univers en gros
le multivers c'est ce qu'on a dans le mc
eu des réalités des branches etc et
l'omni versé la liaison entre deux
univers cinématographique complètement
différent du genre un film réunissant
les héros de marvel studios et disney
avec ceux de sony avec les speedy par
exemple ou encore warner avec les héros
de dc comics etc etc
ces genres le quatrième mur défoncé quoi
bref en vrai je chipote ils vont
certainement trouver une bonne
explication et ils vont gérer la chose
comme d'habitude par contre le marketing
de sony là en ce moment ça s'accélère
énormément vraiment de plus en plus et
je peux vous assurer que le trailer de
spider man nommé comme ça va être une
dinguerie 1 franchement compter sur moi
pour en parler parce que là ça va être
ça être le cas où quoi sony encourage
les fans à voir ou revoir les anciennes
trilogie pour annoncer le plus grand
voyage de spider man jamais connu alors
là les étoiles sont vraiment une fois de
plus clairement alignés mais je sais pas
vous mais je commence à avoir un petit
peu la perception que notre spa dit un
jour et par tom holland et bien
il viendrait peut-être d'une autre
réalité enfin c'est pas assez bizarre
puisque nous savons qu'à terme spies il
retournera chez sony ce sera le même
avec tom holland en acteur etc
et bizarrement tout le background
iconique de spider man est absent dans
le mc eu pas de grosses révélations sur
l'origine de ces pouvoirs pas donc le bn
sony veut expliquer pourquoi dans la
réalité de venom il n'y a pas de spider
man et bah ça sent l'entourloupe un peu
non j'avoue que je pars un petit peu
loin quand même mais c'est tellement
inédit cette situation cependant si
marvel et sony réussissent à conserver
leur accord il y a clairement moyen
d'avoir de grosses dingue rien
franchement et tout ça simplement grâce
au multi vers le cadet si mr 6 est déjà
une preuve en lui même mais le cas de
venom aussi et je vous en avais déjà
parlé aussi dans ma vidéo dédiée mais
sony a les moyens de développer des
films de super vilains de leur côté
qu'ils joueront par la suite dans le
même sens une stratégie marketing
incroyable pour sony car cela obligerait
les fans du mc hugh qui sont en très
grand nombre à regarder bas les films de
chez sony du coup bah oui si on nous
annonce admettons que venom joué par tom
hardy va apparaître dans le mc eu le
temps d'un film
grâce à une réalité alternative et bien
les gens vont aller voir venom 1 et 2
pareil pour les anciennes trilogie ou
encore les si mr 6 dont le projet d'un
film dédié est prévu depuis des années
mais qui n'a jamais vu encore le jour
pour le moment un excellent moyen pour
sony de ne plus être le concurrent de
l'ombre du coup du géant disney et
marvel studios le grand leader suprême
mais de justement profiter de leurs
droits etc pour lier leur univers à
celui du mcg du coup et tout ça le
multivers peut clairement permettre ce
genre de choses bon je finis sur un
dernier petit truc mais c'est quand même
bizarre qu'en ce moment sony balance à
fond sur spider man en termes de
marketing etc
alors qu'il n'y a pas de spider man dans
leur récent film et pire que ça venom 2
sort en septembre
et il en parle moins que speedy
actuellement alors que spider man 3 est
prévu pour décembre
bon bref on va s'arrêter là je vous
avais prévenu ça va être une grosse
vidéo mais franchement bas j'en avais
besoin clairement j'avais trop envie de
partager toutes mes pensées avec vous
mes réflexions
tous mes ressentis mes idées etc bref
j'espère que ça vous a et b et que cela
vous a intéressé évidemment comme
toujours je vous ai proposé quelque
chose de personnel et qui traduit ma
perception des choses avoue du coup de
me dire en commentaire vos idées vos
ressentis concernant tout ça le
multivers et ouganda vision etc
je sens que ça va donner naissance à de
gros pavés intéressant à lire
d'ailleurs j'en parle peu en vidéo mais
si ça vous intéresse g1 discorde ou avec
plusieurs personnes justement de la
chaîne etc
on parle déjà un petit peu de tous ces
sujets et tout quoi dans tous les cas
j'ai très hâte de voir la suite des
événements de continuer à en parler avec
vous de partager avec vous donc voilà
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
justement pour ne rien louper et puis
puis voilà quoi
et puis n'oubliez pas le petit pouce
bleus à me suivre sur instagram ou
encore twitter
et puis bah écoute et que le lay en art
soit avec vous c'était hard rock
allez ciao tôt
[Musique]